- [Interviewer] All right, Kayla.
Kayla, where'd you grow up,
where are you from originally?
- I was born in Sevierville, Tennessee,
but I've been in North
Carolina since I was five.
I'm 29, so.
- [Interviewer] And you came
to West Virginia at what age?
- Last year. Last August.
- Oh, so you're new here?
- Yeah, yup.
I came up here last August with my ex.
- [Interviewer] So, a
man brought you here?
- Yeah. Yup.
- [Interviewer] How different
is the South Western part
of West, Virginia to where you grew up
in Tennessee or North Carolina?
- From Tennessee, I guess
it's a lot different
'cause it's a tourist community,
so during the summertime
it's packed full of people
and during the winter time it's empty.
- [Interviewer] Just
very rural all the time?
- Yeah, it's the same people all the time,
it's the same places all the time, it's.
Winston-Salem, it's so big
and there's so many people,
it's different people all the time.
Yeah.
So, it's definitely different here
compared to Winston or Tennessee,
because it's always the
same thing all the time.
- [Interviewer] And
how was your childhood?
You grew up with both your parents?
- No, my mom left my stepdad,
or my mom left my dad
when I was 17 months old
and married his brother.
So, from 17 months to when I was five,
it was daddy-uncle (laughing).
Uncle-daddy.
- [Interviewer] How would
you describe your childhood?
- I don't really remember
a lot of my childhood.
I was molested when I was six by my uncle,
and doctor says that's
why I don't remember
a lot of my childhood.
- Your uncle being
your mom's second husband?
- My mom's, no, my mom's brother.
- [Interviewer] Okay, I'm
losing track of it (laughing).
- I know, 'cause it
was, it was daddy.uncle,
that kinda throws things off, but.
- [Interviewer] That started at six,
how long did that last?
- It just happened once
that I can recall anyways,
but no she didn't, she
still doesn't believe
that it happened.
- [Interviewer] Your
mom didn't believe you?
- No, she still doesn't.
She doesn't believe the
doctors or anything,
she believes what she wants to.
She's an alcoholic, so I guess addiction
kinda runs in our family.
- [Interviewer] Yeah, that happens a lot.
- Yeah.
- [Interviewer] How far
did you go in school?
- 10th grade.
Not my choice, my step, or my real dad.
I went to a high school in Pigeon Forge.
He kinda lost his mind
a little bit over Christmas.
He didn't have weed, he
is like Jekyll and Hyde
if he doesn't have his pot.
And, he sent me away for
Christmas, and when I came back
he just wasn't right,
and I stayed with my cousin for a few days
and he called and told me
to come and get my stuff,
and I'm scared to go to school
after I came and went into
the house and got my things,
and come to find out, and he
found out truancy was a thing,
and so he put a warrant
out for me being a runaway,
I turned myself in and spent
a few days in juvenile hall.
And they released me
into his custody and he'd
beat the shit out of me,
almost killed me,
and I just never went
back to school after that.
I want to, but life just hasn't
really given me that opportunity yet, but.
- [Interviewer] Did you,
you went out on your own
at what age?
- When i quit school?
- [Interviewer] Yeah, when
you went out on your own
and lived without your parents.
- I I've always kinda
lived it with my parents.
I've always ended up going
back home to my mom's,
it's always been back and
forth, back and forth.
I've been homeless, I was
homeless in new Orleans
and I was homeless in
Michigan and I was homeless
in Florida, but all of this has just been
over the last five years.
- [Interviewer] Is it because of drugs?
- Drugs, it started because of depression,
and a man, I got started on crack
because of a previous relationship,
and I seek to my kid's dad for help,
and, you know, told him what was going on
and asked him to keep the
kids for a little bit longer,
and next thing I know he's telling me
that he's not giving them
back, and I haven't seen
or spoke to them in almost five years.
- [Interviewer] And
you have how many kids?
- I have two, I have an
eight year old daughter
and a six year old son.
- [Interviewer] And they're staying with?
- Their dad and his girlfriend.
Yeah, she's a big blessing.
If it weren't for her, there's no telling
where my kids would be at.
So, she works two full-time jobs
and make sure that they have everything
that they want and need, and they get to
their doctor's appointment sitting.
He's still a deadbeat, but
at least he's got the babies, I guess.
But.
- It's nice
that they're taken care of by somebody.
- Yeah.
- And that you like her.
I didn't, as, I mean,
I wouldn't say that I
like her, (laughing).
- But you're.
- But I'm thankful for her.
Sort of.
- [Interviewer] And how do
you support yourself now?
- All kinds of different
ways, if I can find work
then I'll do it.
I do everything from
painting, to concrete,
to dry wall.
Flooring, I can like flooring,
to having to turn tricks, yeah.
- [Interviewer] A lot
of the girls do that.
- Yeah. I mean, it's easy (giggling).
- [Interviewer] Easy and fast money.
- It's really degrading, and it really is,
it hits your heart and your self respect
and, you know, your self worth,
'cause it kinda makes you
feel a little bit worthless.
But.
- Do you feel bad
about doing it afterwards?
- Oh yeah. Yeah.
Because I mean, that's
not who I am, that's not
what I wanna do, you know?
I wanna do those things with somebody
that I actually care about, you know,
but, I mean, I wanna eat too
and I wanna get high (laughing).
- [Interviewer] What is your drug today?
- Heroin. Yeah.
- Heroine?
- [Interviewer] Yeah, so when you need it,
you need it.
- Yeah.
Like right now I'm a little
under the weather, you know?
But,
my day was just getting started,
like I had just woke up (laughing).
- When I found you?
- Yeah.
Yeah, I woke up and came
straight over that way.
- [Interviewer] Do you have any friends?
- I have a lot of friends here,
I wouldn't call them friends.
I have one good friend, he is actually
who I've been staying
with, his name's Roy.
He's pretty cool.
I definitely wouldn't call them friends,
'cause friends don't lie to one another,
they don't steal from one another
and everybody's steals from you here.
But I know a lot of people,
you know, so that's kinda helpful.
- [Interviewer] Giving you a new trust?
- No. Not here or anywhere.
Just God.
I don't even trust myself
really, but I do trust God.
So.
- Are you religious?
- More so spiritual, I guess.
I mean, I think every religions' right,
'cause at the end of the
day, whether you believe
in that door knob over there,
or you believe in yourself,
is through your God, you
still believe in something
bigger than what you are.
So, I don't know.
I guess I would say I'm more so spiritual,
I believe that, I like to
think there's a God, you know,
that's why I'm still
here, but I shouldn't be.
- Are you happy.
- No.
- [Interviewer] You're
depressed sometimes?
What's been the toughest
part of your life?
Losing your kids?
- Yeah. My family.
- [Interviewer] What's been
the best time of your life?
- Hmm. Being a mom.
- [Interviewer] Do you ever
consider leaving this area?
- Oh God, every day.
Every day.
- It's a tough region,
I mean, it seems like
everyone is into drugs
and there's all kinds of other
crazy things going on here.
- Yeah.
I mean, if I go back home,
I'm still gonna be using,
but,
I'll be around people that
act like they care more,
at least, even if they don't,
they at least act like they do, you know.
I've got more places that I can stay,
so I don't have to worry about being cold
during the winter time.
But, it's closer to my kids
that I know I can't be near,
so it kinda helps being further away.
- [Interviewer] This is
a very difficult part
of the country it seems, that
so many people are into drugs.
- [Kayla] Oh yeah, I mean it's,
it's, it's really bad here,
that's all I hear about all
the time is so-and-so died,
so-and-so OD'd and you
know, there was a guy here
named Too Tall, and he was,
they went up into his house
and they cut him ear to ear
while he sat in his recliner,
and then everybody just
ran up into his house
while there was still crime scene tape up
and stole all of his
stuff out of his house.
Like, people are so heartless here
because all they care
about is getting high,
and how they're gonna get that next buzz
or just even really now, you're
not even getting high now,
you're just getting well.
But.
- [Interviewer] It seems
like there's so many,
it looks like such a beautiful
and serene part of the country,
and yet you start hearing
all these stories of
crazy human behavior.
- Yeah.
It's, oh well I don't know what
the word would be for that.
It's fucked up.
- [Interviewer] That's the
word for it (laughing).
That's the word.
- [Kayla] It's such a beautiful place,
that's what makes me wanna stay here,
but the people are just so ugly.
It's unreal, you know.
- [Interviewer] In some parts
of the state, maybe here,
maybe not, there's sex
trafficking going on?
- [Kayla] Yeah. Yeah.
I mean, it's real, I didn't believe it
until I met some people, I mean,
they kidnap kids, they
kidnap women, you know?
I mean, every time I go out,
whether it's day or night,
you know, I have to fear,
especially if I get
into somebody else's car
I have to worry about whether or not
I'm gonna be shipped off to another state
or across the border.
You know, I've met three people
here just in the last year
that had been kidnapped.
I don't really know what
happened to them or anything,
but I know that they were kidnapped
and they were held hostage
in a place, you know?
So that's scary, you don't
think that those kinds of things
happen right here, you
know, where you live at.
That's something that happens in Mexico
or California maybe, you know,
but not in West Virginia.
- [Interviewer] Here
it's so, everyone is so,
everything is so remote
that it would be easy
to get away with.
- Yeah.
- [Interviewer] You want to
kill somebody and throw them
in a ditch, no one's ever
gonna find out.
- Oh yeah.
You go up to Irish mountain,
nobody would ever know.
I mean, there's so many
places in the woods here,
like there's places that
I've gone and and walked into
and I'm like, "Damn, this
would be a killer place
"to hide a body," you know.
- [Interviewer] The coyotes
and the bears would find it
before anybody.
- Oh yeah.
I mean, it's scary.
I mean, at this point in
time, you know what I mean,
your whole life could
just stop and be over with
because of somebody else.
And it's crazy to think that,
but it's real, you have to,
and people don't think about that
unless they're living this
lifestyle, and it's a shame
because even if I'm not getting high
and I'm working a full-time
job at the hospital
and I go home, my two kids could be gone.
They could have been outside
playing and got snatched up,
and people don't think about that.
You know, people need to watch their kids
a little bit better and keep them close,
you know, and watch yourself,
'cause there's people out here
that don't care, they're really,
really, really don't care.
I mean, they'll send you
off and put you in a house
with 10 other Hispanic
males taking care of them
and fucking all of them, you know.
Like kind of,
it's not something anybody
should have to go through.
- [Interviewer] What's the
craziest thing you've seen?
Since you've been here?
- There's a few people here
that when they get high,
it's like they're being exorcized,
like they're possessed and
they're being exorcized.
Like they, they contort and convulse
and smack themselves, and, I mean it's.
And there's been times
that I've seen them do this
and we're doing the same exact stuff,
and like, it just drives me wild
to think like, there's,
I mean, is it something
in their brain that
makes them act like that
when they get high?
Why would you wanna get high
if it makes you act like that?
Like, I would be embarrassed,
kind of to have people see
me behave in that manner
when I got high.
Like I get high and I just
take a nap, if I get high,
but like, I don't know.
If I got high then that happened to me,
I wouldn't get high anymore.
- [Interviewer] What do you
think the core of drug abuse is?
Is it.
- Depression.
- [Interviewer] Is it
something that happened
in your childhood that you're
trying to numb the pain of,
the (indistinct).
- I mean, It could be
your childhood, it could
be your early adult life.
I mean, I didn't start using drugs until.
I mean, I didn't, I messed
with cocaine back when I was
like 17, 18 but I quit for years,
never touched anything but weed,
and when me and my kids' dad separated
and got into a new relationship, new kids,
I just, something snapped
and I started getting depressed and.
I was 24,
before I started getting high, you know.
And I used to say that
I would never in my life
ever stick a needle in
my arm, and now I do it
50 times a day, you know.
I have to, now it's to the point to where
I have to go chase
money, to go chase dope,
to go chase somebody,
to help me do my dope,
cause I can't do it myself.
You know, it's tiring.
- [Interviewer] What's
the most important lesson
you've learned in your life?
- It doesn't matter how
bad people are to you,
if you feel like you're a good person,
then continue to be a good person.
Don't be petty like everybody else.
Just because somebody stole
from you, doesn't mean that
it's okay to steal from them, you know?
I don't know, I just try to,
through all the bad things that I've seen,
I still try to be a good person,
and help as many people as I can,
even though I can barely help myself.
You know, if I can get
somebody else high, then,
you know, make them feel
better for the day, then,
you know, cool.
If I can help somebody eat something
that has ate a couple of days
and that's cool, you know,
but it's important.
It's important to me to
just always be a good person,
because there's so much ugly out there.
Yeah.
- [Interviewer] All right, Kayla.
Thank you so much for talking with me.
- Yeah.
- [Interviewer] Good luck with everything,
and I hope you get your kids back.
- Thanks. Yeah, me too (laughing).
- You'd be a great mom.
- Yeah. I was.
- How old are you?
- 29.
- [Interviewer] 29.
You're still super young.
- Yeah. I feel so old (laughing).
- [Interviewer] How old are your kids?
- [Kayla] My daughter, her
name's Lily, she's eight,
she was born September 11th, 2012,
and then my son Liam, he was born 6/27/14.
Yeah. They're good babies.
They're beautiful too.